ist martin sein das stimmt diese blumen
sind für sie vielen dank marten ich
liebe rosen dieser film ist kein wein
hast ist es noch nicht mal einen nach
war nichts für diese gegend so ruhig
sauber hübsch und wo lebst du machen in
einer nicht so schöne gegend in einem
nicht so schönen haus the killing of the
sacred dir des griechen giorgos
lanthimos erzählt eine sehr unangenehme
geschichte wie sind seit der gestartet
ein arzt hat einen kunstfehler begangen
und er soll jetzt dafür büßen ein junge
der sohn eines verstorbenen patienten
nähert sich ihm dringt in sein leben ein
zunächst freundliche später auch immer
zudringlicher weise und enthüllt ihm
dass er sich an ihm rächen
er möchte den tod seines vaters dadurch
gesund sehen dass der chirurg selbst ein
mitglied der familie getötet was sonst
so droht ist der junge an ohne dass wir
wissen aus welchem recht er das
eigentlich tut und mit welcher macht
dahinter sonst würden alle sterben die
dem chirurgen am herzen liegen es gibt
einen weg das zu beenden was wir dazu
brauchen ist der kern eines baby codiert
das blut einer taube und das schema
einer jungfrau und alles vor
sonnenaufgang verbrennen
landes nimmt ein genre in diesem fall
des horrorfilms und dreht es sozusagen
gegen die eigene richtung verändert
völlig die grund ausleuchtung sonst ist
im horrorfilm immer alles von
übermenschlichen übernatürlichen
gewaltigen kräften gesteuert
hier geschieht nichts was wir nicht
kennen also unser gleichen alter und
dennoch steckt dahinter eine logik die
alles normale umdreht um stück die
buchstäblich die geschichte aus der
kurve trägt
[Musik]
warum erzählt uns langsam aus diese
geschichte
vielleicht möchte er nur erzählen was
passiert wenn wünsche gedanken auf
einmal zur wirklichkeit werden und die
welt verändern
es tut mir wirklich leid wegen war das
ist nichts schlimmes doch ist in denen
einige schauspieler die wir gut kennen
in ganz anderen rollen als wir es
gewohnt sind colin farell hier in einer
passiven und seltsamen
eingetrübten und überschatteten rolle
nicole kidman die in ihren besten rollen
immer etwas geisterhaftes etwas nicht
ganz von dieser welt hafte es hat hier
als erscheinung die sich abends im
ehebett wie eine betäubte patienten mit
ausgebreiteten armen hinlegt damit ihr
mann über sie herfallen kann ich hoffe
nur an und ihr zu sagen dass ich heute
einen wunderbaren tag hatte das freut
mich wirklich sehr wie killing of the
sacred dir das ist eine anspielung auf
den mythos von iphigenie
im alten griechenland
ihr vater agamemnon hatte im heiligen
hain der göttin artemis gejagten einen
hirsch getötet und würde deshalb dazu
verurteilt seine eigene tochter
iphigenie auf einem altar zu opfern
langsam muss spielt mit dem kino aber
spielt auf eine sehr ernsthafte weise
damit er lässt uns dinge sehen die wir
nicht kennen oder dinge die wir kennen
in neuem licht das macht seinen film
sehenswert ich möchte ihn schauen ich
den preis der 14 und kleine kinder den
preis dafür zahlen müssen
ich trete sie ein